Okay, so I wanted to start by playing
the beauty contest again. Last week uh
for two reasons. Last week I kind of
messed it up and I described
a mixture of the game we actually played
in a more complicated game that I play
in my other class. So, I want to set the
record straight here, and I also want to
see how the results maybe have changed
since the first time we played. So, if
you haven't made an account yet, you can
log in here and put in the password or
put in the the class code.
Try to join this game now and let me say
a little bit about how it works.
So, remember uh this is the beauty
contest. You're going to guess a number
between 1 and 100.
That computer is going to collect
everyone's guesses and compute the
average of those guesses.
And the winner is going to be the person
whose guess is closest to 2/3 of the
average of the class's guesses.
Uh so, let's start
and play this and uh
see what happens.
So, did we learn from last week? Let's
see. So, in this case the average choice
was 18.
And the winning choice was 12. So, I
think last week what was it the first
time? Maybe 25 was the the winning bid.
So, what you see is again we're shifting
a little bit. Um I wonder I was actually
expecting we might shift a bit more. No
one went too close to zero. Um
if we really were ultra ultra rational,
there's an argument that everyone should
uh guess zero and we'll see the formal
argument for that later in the course.
But if you're not sure if everyone else
is rational, then uh maybe this is uh a
pretty reasonable performance. Again, we
had a few people going a little crazy
and and guessing 100. I think that's
probably not a good idea.
Uh okay, so let's uh put this down and
get started.
So, let me start with just a very brief
review of what we did
last class or I'll say
say yesterday, but I guess last class.
So, last class we talked about
individual decision-making.
This class we're going to start talking
about interactive decision-making where
we have multiple players making
decisions and the best decision for each
of them depends upon the decisions that
other players are making.
So, just some notation to remember from
last class.
It's really just two pieces you need to
remember.
From last class we said that there's
some set Z
of consequences or outcomes.
And we defined a von Neumann-Morgenstern
utility
that assigned some real number
to every single consequence or outcome.
I'll use those two terms
interchangeably.
And then we defined capital U to be the
expected utility. So, what this does is
it assigns to every lottery
every lottery over consequences
the expected utility that the agent gets
from that lottery. And remember a
lottery would be something like this.
So, if there are M consequences
then a lottery is a vector P
that specifies
M different probabilities that sum to
one.
And the interpretation is that P1 is the
probability under this lottery that
outcome that the first consequence is
realized
all the way up to PM, which is the
probability that the Mth
consequence is realized. And I realized
last week
I think I used P in two different ways,
both as a probability and as a vector.
So, here this is a vector. Uh maybe I'll
put a hat on it here, but I may not use
hats throughout the course. But keep in
mind that P will usually be a vector,
but these little Ps are uh numbers.
These are probabilities inside the
vector.
Okay, so now today
the plan is to move to interactive
decision-making.
And let me just give an outline of the
three topics we're going to cover.
The first is what we're going to define
what we call an extensive form game.
This is one way of representing a game.
Well, what is a game? Well, think of a
game as a multi-agent decision problem.
Yesterday we talked about the decision
problem faced by an individual.
Today when we think about multiple
individuals making choices that interact
we're going to we're going to call that
a game.
An extensive form game is going to be a
very detailed representation of the game
that specifies all the details that
might possibly matter about the game.
Then later
we're going to talk about a strategic
form game
which
you can think of as a summary of the
extensive form game. It isolates or
identifies the essential elements of the
game for strategic analysis. And it
throws out some of the details that are
not explicitly relevant when we're
analyzing the game.
And the key way that we jump from an
extensive form game to a strategic form
game is the notion of a strategy.
And I think this is the single most
important definition in the course. So,
after we talk about extensive form
games, we'll define what a strategy is
and then we'll move to strategic form
games.
I think most points that people lose
throughout this course on exams are
because they haven't thought carefully
about what a strategy is and what the
right definition of a strategy is. So,
I'd really encourage you to to focus on
this definition.
Okay.
So, let's
maybe I'll start a new board here
actually.
So, I want to start with two examples of
extensive form games and then motivated
by those examples, I'll present the
general theory. But I think if I do the
general theory first, it's just a lot of
notation and it's not very concrete. So,
let's start with two really simple
examples.
Um
the first is an investment game.
And this will actually only have one
strategic player.
Games don't have to have multiple
players. They're usually more
interesting when there's multiple
players, but it's allowed for there to
just be one player. So, let's think that
there is a single player.
We'll call them player one.
And we're going to represent this game
using what's called a decision tree,
which you may have seen in some other
courses.
So, this one player is choosing whether
to make a safe investment or risky
investment.
So, they have two actions.
Safe
and risky.
And the safe investment is always going
to pay the same amount of money.
But the risky investment may pay a lot
of money or it may pay a little money.
They're not sure.
So, the way we're going to represent
that is under the risky investment
there's actually going to be a move by a
player that we'll call nature.
Now, nature is a special kind of player.
They're not a strategic player like
everyone else.
But it we often find it helpful to think
of them as a player when we represent
this game.
And here we think of nature as choosing
what the payoff of this
asset is going to be if they make the
risky investment. And in this example
there's two possibilities.
The payoff is only $3.
Uh the monetary payout is either $3 or
$1.
And I have to tell you the probabilities
of these two outcomes, right? So,
whenever nature chooses something,
nature chooses that from some
distribution, from some lottery.
And I'm going to indicate the
probabilities like this, half and half.
Um now up here I don't really need to
use nature, but maybe I will just to be
really precise. So, here nature is
always going to choose a payout of $2.
So, maybe if I really want to be
precise, I'll put a one here. And this
is a one not a seven. Sometimes
I get a little crazy with the hat.
So, this says if I choose the safe
investment I'm certain to get $2.
If I choose the risky investment, then
there's a half chance that I get $3
and a half chance that I get $1.
But I would argue this is not a complete
specification of the game. What's
missing here?
If I want to specify this this problem,
what have I not told you?
Yeah? Preferences? Preferences, right?
And it's tempting to say, "Oh, well, all
I want to do is maximize expected
monetary amount." But as we talked about
last class
some people are risk-averse, some people
are risk-loving. We have to capture
preferences.
So, what we need to write down is what
my utility is from each of these
outcomes. So, we're going to have
specify my utility from $2
my utility from $3 and my utility from
$1.
And you know, there's a lot of choices
we could make.
But maybe we'll say
1.5
two
and 0.9. This is some example.
So, it's important to understand that
the game specifies the consequences
but also the payoffs from those
consequences.
And it can be particularly tempting when
you have monetary payouts, so when the
consequences are money, to get confused
about that distinction, but there's
still a crucial distinction between the
consequence, which here is measured in
dollars,
and the utility the player gets from
that consequence, which is measured in
utils.
So, this here is a von
Neumann-Morgenstern utility.
Like we talked about last class.
Okay, so that's a very simple game.
There's really one There's one strategic
player together with nature.
Uh let's now do
a game that actually has two players.
So, let's really get into game theory.
And um I'm going to call this
the BOS game.
So, historically this game is called the
battle of the sexes. Um
I think
today I'd like to try to avoid that
terminology, so I'll just call it BOS,
think of it as Boston, but if you read
old game theory books, uh they'll often
call this the battle of the sexes game.
So, what's the idea of this game, at
least the the version we're going to
tell?
Um
you have two friends, and they're
choosing between two activities.
So, let's say since it's Boston, let's
say going to a Celtics game or going to
a Red Sox game.
And the idea is they have to choose
which activity to do.
And they're they're good friends, so if
they go to different activities, they
don't have any fun. If you go to the
Celtics game and I go to the Red Sox
game, we're each all alone and we're
both sad.
So, we both like to go to the same
activity. We'd like to be together at
that activity, but one of us would
rather that we be together at the
Celtics game because they're more of a
basketball fan.
And the other person would rather that
they be together at a Red Sox game.
So, this is a what's Why I think this
game is is so important and why it's
gotten a lot of attention is it features
both
conflict
maybe conflict and cooperation.
It has a conflict of interest because
there's one player who'd like that you
both go to the Celtics game.
And there's the other player who'd like
you both to go to the Red Sox game. So,
you have some conflict of interest
between where you go.
But you also have maybe cooperation or
coordination is maybe a better term. Let
me say coordination.
But there's also a coordination aspect
to it because you'd like to go to the
same activity.
You'd like to be at the same place.
Uh and this combination of conflict and
coordination is present in uh in a lot
of situations far beyond this very
simple uh game.
So, let's draw this out.
We're going to say player one is first
going to choose whether to go to the
Celtics game or the Red Sox game, and
I'll so call this
C and R.
And let me just be clear when I say
Celtics game or Red Sox game, that's not
the formal sense of a game we're talking
about here. That's game as in an
athletic game.
So, player one is choosing between C and
R.
And then player two is choosing
also between C and R.
Now,
the outcomes are kind of already
immediate from the way I've written it,
right? What is the outcome here?
The outcome here is that we watch the
Celtics game together.
And the outcome here is that player one
watches the Red Sox game by herself, and
player two watches the Celtics game by
herself.
But again, if we want to fully specify
the game, we have to say what payoffs
are. So, we're going to write down
payoffs here.
And what I'm going to assume is that
player one is the player who prefers the
Celtics. So, if they both go to the
Celtics game,
the payoffs are 4 3.
Now, notice a key difference here.
With a single player game, I only had to
specify one utility at each of these
consequences. But now that I have two
players, I have to specify each player's
utility from that consequence.
And the convention we're going to use is
that if we have players one and two, the
first player's payoff is going to come
first, and the second player's payoff is
going to come second. So, this is how we
specify everyone's payoffs from this
consequence. If we had more players,
we'd we'd keep having commas and we'd
keep adding more numbers.
Now, the other one we'll write down is
RR. So, this is again where we've
coordinated on going to the same sports
event, but we've coordinated on the Red
Sox game. And player two is the one who
likes the Red Sox more. So, here this
down here
is going to be 3 4.
And then to keep things simple, we'll
make the other payoff 0 0.
So, the idea is if you go to the the
game by yourself, you're so sad it
doesn't even matter who's playing.
You're just sitting by yourself and
you're sad. You get a payoff of zero,
but uh here we see the
conflict.
Okay, so a very simple game.
Um
I don't know. In this game, who would
you
rather be? Do you have any intuition
about
what might happen
in this game?
Or which player you'd like to be?
Who would you rather be based on the way
we've written the game?
Yeah?
Player one. Okay, and tell me why.
Because they pick first. Because they
pick first. So, exactly, and I'm getting
at a crucial thing. What is implicit in
the way I've written this, and what you
see is important for the analysis, is
not just that they pick first, but that
player two observes the pick that they
make.
So, implicitly the way I've written this
is that player two gets to see what
player one does.
And can you walk me through why if
player two sees what you do, why you
think player one's in a really strong
position?
So, what's going to happen? What's your
prediction about what would happen?
No matter what player one does, player
two is
better off than following suit.
Right. So, in this case, I'm player one.
I like the Celtics. What I want to do is
I want to go to the Celtics game and
make sure you know I'm going to go I'm
going there. And once player two already
knows that I'm at the Celtics game,
well, they don't really want to be
alone, so they're going to follow me to
the Celtics game.
So, in this case, the fact that player
one moves first, and that move is
observed, gives them the power to select
which game they end up going to.
But what you can see is if player two
didn't observe what player one did,
then this would be a quite different
game, right? An alternative game would
be we move simultaneously. It's always a
bit harder to motivate this in the world
of instant communication, but in the old
days, people would have to agree about a
place to meet up, and they might
simultaneously choose where they would
go to meet up, and you might not observe
where the other person had chosen to go.
So, we need a notation for that. So, if
we wanted to say the version of the game
where player two does not observe what
player one did, we would indicate that
using a dotted line here.
So, the dotted line, maybe I'll write
this over here,
means
player two, P2, does not observe player
one's move.
So, you can think of this essentially as
a simultaneous move game.
Technically, the way we wrote the tree,
player one is moving first,
and player two is moving second,
but because player two doesn't get to
see what player one does, it's
effectively as if they were moving
simultaneously.
Okay, are there any questions
on uh
these games here?
Okay, so now what I'd like to do is
present
the general definition of a game. So,
these are two examples of a game that we
want to capture, and we want to
introduce a much more general definition
that can cover all the examples that
we're going to discuss in this course.
So, formally, we do it over here.
An extensive form game
Well, first we need a word for
this decision tree that I drew.
Formally, this is what's called a rooted
tree. So, let me say an extensive form
game is a
This is a fancy name. All it means is it
looks like this. The root is where you
start.
This is the root, and then it comes out
like this.
Sometimes people write trees vertically.
Sometimes you write them from left to
right. Doesn't really matter.
Um the formal notion of a tree is that
at any point I look at,
there's a unique path back to the root.
So, just so we kind of understand what's
not allowed,
if I had something
like this,
this would not be allowed
because here's my root.
If I look at this point, there's two
different ways to get back to the root.
So, this So, this is not a graph theory
course. We're not getting into too many
technicalities, but basically there
can't be any any loops or any cycles uh
in the tree, and that's what we we mean
by rooted tree.
And the interpretation of the root is
that's where things start. So, remember
implicitly when we write an extensive
form game, there's some notion of time,
right? We think of time starting at the
root, and then as we move forward in
time, we move throughout the tree.
Okay, let me erase this since this is
not what we allow.
I want to make
So, it's a rooted tree specifying
four things.
So, I want to first specify each of them
kind of informally, and then I want to
talk formally how they appear uh on the
graphs. There's four things it
specifies, and I like using the acronym
PAPI, papi, to remember it.
So, this is
players, actions, payoffs, information.
So, let me write that down. Yes. Are
these required to be finite trees?
Good question. Um
we're going to do what's often done when
in kind of intro game theory class, and
when we formally define it, we'll assume
things are finite to create so that have
issues, but then we'll go to some
examples where things are infinite. So,
basically what I would say is
to carefully define infinite games,
there are some issues. So, we'll only
consider infinite games where things are
very well-behaved, and we won't formally
define exactly what well-behaved is.
It's just if you see an infinite game,
trust that it's going to be
well-behaved.
Um but, you know, if we go to the if we
think of the Keynesian beauty contest
that we started with, we required you to
choose a number between 1 and 100. It
had to be an integer. But, what if you
could choose a real number between 0 and
1 and 100? Now, all of a sudden you have
an infinite game, and and that could be
a realistic uh model or a useful model.
Great. So, P is for players.
A is for actions.
P is for
payoffs.
And I is for information.
So, I could define these things, but I
think people
should have a pretty intuitive sense of
what these mean, right? The players are
the agents, the actors in our game.
The actions are the choices that they
make.
So, for instance, in this game player
one chose between safe and risky. Over
here, player two chose between going to
the Celtics game and going to the Red
Sox game.
Payoffs are what we define at the end.
This is the utilities that people get
from the consequences of the game.
And then information, we're going to
have to be a bit more careful about
defining this, but it captures what we
were initially discussing here. Things
like does player two know what player
one chose when it's player two's turn to
move?
Um and I want to just use a few put a
few synonyms up here because I have a
tendency throughout the course to use a
few different words to mean the same
thing, and I just want us to be on the
same page about what those mean. So, I
might say action
or I might say moves. Those mean the
same thing.
And I might say payoffs or I might say
utilities.
And those mean the same thing.
One really important thing is payoffs
always means utilities.
So, even in this game here,
here I would say your payoff is 1.5.
What I mean by that is your utility is
1.5. I'm not talking about the monetary
payoff. So, if I don't use the word
monetary, we're always talking about
utilities. Why? Well,
it's really the utilities that matter.
The monetary payoffs are sort of in the
background, but everything really comes
down to the utilities.
Okay. So, players,
I think intuitively we all know how we
need to specify this, but I just want to
be a little bit more formal.
Well, the players, the way we specify it
is we put labels on the nodes in the
tree, right? But, notice not every node
gets a label.
In this game, these nodes don't get a a
player label, they get a utility label.
So, really, if we look at this game, we
see these two different kinds of nodes.
There's
the nodes
like this, 1 2 3, which are decision
nodes. These are nodes in the tree where
people take decisions or choose, maybe
I'll say, actions, moves, maybe I'll add
one more synonym, decisions.
And then we have nodes like this, which
are at the end of the game, and these
specify consequences.
So, let me say the rooted tree, let me
go a little up here,
it has nodes
is some set H.
Why do we call the nodes capital H?
Because H reminds us of history.
And with a tree, every node exactly
tells us the history of play in the
game. Let's look at this.
At this node, well, nothing has
happened. So, the history is nothing.
At this node, the history is player one
chose C.
And at this node, the history is player
one chose C, and then player two chose
R.
Notice that this gets back to the
problem
with our example here, right?
If we had
two paths that took went to the same
node, well, now interpreting this as a
history becomes unclear. Because if
we're here, well, did we get here by
following that history
or did we get here by following that
history? And that shows we've done
something wrong in the way we've
specified the game. We want to uniquely
specify the history of of actions at
each node in the game, and that's why we
ruled that out.
So, within the set of nodes H,
we'll say Z, which is a subset of H,
these are the terminal nodes.
And then H minus Z, these are the
decision nodes.
So, I could define this formally, but I
think we should know what this means. Z
subset of H means there's some
subcollection of nodes that are the
terminal nodes.
In this game here,
the set H contains, well, 1 2 3 4 5 6 7.
So, in this game, H would have seven
nodes.
Four of them are terminal nodes. So,
these four nodes at the end
would be in the set Z,
which is a subset of all the seven. So,
we have seven histories, seven nodes all
together. Four of them are terminal
nodes in the set Z.
And then you may not have seen this
notation before, but H set minus Z means
everything that's in H that's not in Z.
So, over here in this example,
we have seven nodes all together.
Four of them are in Z. What's left?
What's not in Z? Well, it's these three
nodes, 1 2 3, and these are called
decision nodes because these are nodes
where players make decisions.
Once we get here, there are no decisions
to be made, these are just consequences.
It's not a coincidence
that we use the term Z
for the terminal nodes,
because Z is exactly playing the role
that Z played last week in our
individual game.
So, at the at the terminal nodes of our
game, we have some consequence
which lives in some set Z, and we have
von Neumann-Morgenstern utilities over
those consequences. Of course, before,
we just had one VNM utility, and now we
have one for every player.
So, we'll talk about that in a second.
So, what are the players? We'll usually
label them I equals
one up to N.
So, we could have a one-player game, a
two-player game.
These are the strategic players, and
then sometimes we also have nature. So,
maybe I'll say and nature.
So, nature is kind of a special player
that we sometimes also add to the game
if there's uncertainty in the game. So,
over here,
this game had player one as a strategic
player,
and it had nature.
This game had two strategic players,
player one and player two.
Now, we need the actions, moves, or
decisions. Well, crucially, these are,
I'll say, labeled
on the edges of the tree.
And we could be really formal and
precise, but I think it's easier just to
see what we mean.
So, let's take this history here. It's
player one's turn to move. At this node,
player one has two choices or two
actions, safe and risky.
We represent those two actions with
edges coming out of the node, and we
label each edge with the corresponding
action.
Similarly, over here,
when it's player two's turn to move at
this node, player two has two choices, C
and R. We represent those with edges,
and we label them according to the
actions that they are.
And
if you have a math background, you may
think, "Oh, these labels are kind of
arbitrary." It turns out the labels are
pretty are are quite fundamental in
something we'll do later. So, the labels
are not arbitrary. I'll I'll make that
uh point now.
Payoffs or utilities, well, based on
what I've said, can anyone guess
how we're going to specify the payoffs
or utilities in this game?
Any thoughts?
I'm shy. Yeah?
Uh set
Say Say again?
>> Set of utilities associated with each
outcome.
Exactly. And the way we're going to
write that is we're going to have N
utility functions, one for each player.
So, we're going to say we're going to
have utility function UI
from Z to R
for I equals one to N.
What does that mean? It says for each
player I, we're going to specify that
player I's von Neumann-Morgenstern
utility function over all of the
outcomes. So, this is going to assign a
real number in R to every single outcome
of the game.
Now, notice we've grouped things a
little differently. Here, I'm grouping
things by player. So, for player I, this
function says how much utility does that
player I get from every single
consequence.
Well, the way we wrote it on the tree,
we actually grouped it by consequences.
So, associated with this node is
U1 of that node,  U2 of that
node. So, if you want to sort of connect
it to the definition,
all these numbers here would correspond
to the function U1.
And all these numbers here
would correspond to the function U2.
So, technically, what I put here is
U1 of this outcome,  U2 of this
outcome.
Or consequence, same thing.
And these are, I should emphasize, von
Neumann-Morgenstern utilities,
just like we said last week, so that
when players face uncertainty, they
evaluate lotteries over consequences
using expected utility.
Great. And then the last thing is
information is going to be represented
with something called information sets,
and that's going to take
a new board to talk about. So, let me
pause here and see are there any
questions on what I've done so far?
Okay.
It's a little tight at the bottom.
So now let's talk about information
sets.
So
for each player I
So let me just say it in words first. We
want to look at the game
and we want to look at all the nodes
where player I
is called to move. And this is
important. So up here, when I said
players I equals one through N, part of
naming those players is also assigning a
player to every single node in the tree.
And that means that if I fix a given
player I, I can ask, what are the nodes
in the tree where that player I is
called to act?
So what which of the decision nodes is
player I the one making the decision?
So I'll say for each player I
the decision nodes of player I
And they'd all be connected, but just to
kind of give an illustration, maybe the
nodes are something like this. There'd
be lines between in between them, but
let's just focus on the nodes for now.
The decision nodes of player I are
partitioned into information sets. And
I'll explain what that means.
A partition is a fancy math word to say
we have a group of things. We have a we
have a collection of things and we're
going to
put them into groups. We're just going
to break them up into groups.
So for instance, one way of partitioning
this
would be
that. That's a partition. I have five
things. I put two things together in
this group. These two things together in
this group and one thing by itself in
this group. So the rules of a partition
are what you think. Nothing could be in
two groups.
And nothing could be can be
uh not in any group. So everything's in
exactly one group and that group could
be it by itself like we have here.
That's allowed. But we're just think of
you have a pile of candy on the ground
and we can just push it into piles um on
the ground.
What is the interpretation?
The interpretation is that player I
can only tell
which group they're in, which
information set they're in, but not
which node they're in within that
information set. Let me say that.
So player I
observes
the information set.
So in this case we have three
information sets, maybe I1
I2 and I3.
Whenever the player moves, they know
which information set they're in. But
they don't know which node inside the
information set they're in.
Now of course, if a node is by itself
then they effectively observe which node
they're at. Because if I know I'm in
this information set, then I certainly
know which node I'm at.
But if I know only that I'm at this
information set, I'm not sure whether
I'm at this node or I'm at this node.
Now
here, that's exactly what we're
capturing on this graph. But sometimes
it's cleaner instead of drawing a circle
around the two nodes, just to put a
dotted line between them. So what we did
here is exactly representing this
information partition, but we just did
it in a slightly more compact way. So
often, you know, an alternative thing,
maybe I'll give an example, if you had
three nodes
or specifically if you have two nodes,
you might draw a dotted line between
them instead of a circle. And that just
means the same thing, but it it means
things get a little less messy.
And I should say this is not an
information set. This is just me
indicating something. So
pretend that's not there.
And let's go to the interpretation. So
what we said when these are in the same
information set, when it's player two's
turn to move, what do they know?
They know that they're either at this
history or they're at this history.
So let's say that in words, what they
know is player one has chosen something.
But they don't know which thing player
one has chosen.
Either
player one chose to go to the Celtics
game
or player one chose to go to the Red Sox
game. They know player one chose one of
those things, but they don't know which
one.
If we erase this information set
now these two nodes are in separate
information sets.
And if they're in separate information
sets, player two does observe the choice
that player one makes. Because they know
either they're at this singleton
information set that only contains this
node
or they're at this singleton information
set that only contains this node. So
they know exactly what choice player one
made and this is the formal way that
we're going to model observability.
Yes. For like simultaneous decision
making, do you prefer to use the
information set notation or do you ever
like take a decision node and have two
players kind of belonging to it?
So we're always going to do the first
thing. So we every every node always has
exactly one player. If we want to
capture simultaneity, we always capture
through information sets. So great
question. So nodes are never going to
have two players associated with them.
Always just one. Good question.
Um
Okay. So one final comment is
if a player can observe everything
then what partition does that correspond
to?
If I observe everything, I have no
uncertainty about uh
who's played before me.
Well then just everything's in its own
group, right? So that would be I have a
circle over this, I have a circle over
this.
And in that case we sometimes call
these, maybe I'll give a word for that,
a singleton information set.
A singleton is just a set with one node
inside it.
So if I'm ever at a singleton
information set, I know exactly which
node I'm at.
And if a player always knows exactly
where they are, then their partition
consists only of singletons.
None of their information sets contains
more than one node.
Uh any questions here?
Yes.
What about other information that might
be unknown to the decision maker such as
such as the path?
Good question.
So here what we've assumed is that um
the payoffs of each consequence are
known.
Okay? If there's some uncertainty about
what my payoff payout is, then we need
to model that as different consequences.
So just like we did here, basically when
I chose the risky investment, we didn't
assign a utility directly to the
investment. What we said is well we
don't know how the investment's going to
turn out and we said if I get different
utilities, then those are really
different outcomes or different
consequences. So we need to split them
up. So I would say, you know,
consequences always pin down and specify
utilities exactly. If you feel like
you're not sure what your utility is,
then you should split those consequences
up and represent them differently. I
have in relation to other players
Same thing.
So if I if there's some consequence, if
I'm not sure what the other player's
payoff is
then we should represent it that is two
different consequences where the other
player gets different payoffs. Maybe
I'll get the same payoff at those two
consequences, but the other player will
get different payoffs.
Um and and we'll see uh examples of that
throughout the course. So I think this
framework is actually
much more general than it may at first
to seem. A lot of these assumptions, oh
we know exactly what our payoffs are, we
know all these things, can be can
capture much richer environments with
the appropriate interpretation of what
the information sets are, what nature is
and what the consequences are.
Um
Yeah. And was there a question here or
no?
So maybe not. Okay.
Well, I think there's one problem with
this definition.
And so we need a little more structure
here.
The problem with this definition is what
if I had two information sets
or two two nodes, let's take this that
are in the same information set
but the actions that I'm allowed to take
at those two nodes are different.
Now we have a problem because we've
implicitly assumed that I know what my
actions are. If I didn't know what my
actions were, then there'd be no way I
could even take the action, so we're in
trouble. So we've assumed I know what
actions I can choose.
But if we had two nodes
where I had different feasible actions,
then I would definitely know that I'm at
different nodes because I could tell
that at one of the nodes I had a
different action available.
So we need to impose a restriction on
the way we define information sets so
that that property doesn't that never
occurs.
So
conditions on information sets.
And there's really two main conditions
that we need.
And the first main condition is
capturing what I just said that um
the player must have
So I'll say player I
has same
feasible
actions
at all nodes in in the same information
set.
So just to make it a little more
concrete
if we want to put this in the same
information set
this is okay here because player two is
choosing between C and R at this node
and they're choosing between C and R at
this node.
But if I tried to add something else,
say H, I stay home now we have a
problem.
Because when the player gets to this
node and he knows he he's able to stay
home, he knows that he must be at this
node.
And if he sees that staying home is not
feasible, he knows he must be at this
node, and therefore those can't be in
the same information set.
So, let me
erase this.
But, that's all that this says.
Notice, if all of players a player's
information sets are singletons, well,
then this is automatically satisfied. If
I only have one node in my information
set, then of course I have the same
actions feasible at every node because
there's only one of them. So, this is
what we might say vacuously true,
automatically true
with a singleton information set, but it
has bite if my information set has
multiple nodes.
And then there's one more restriction
that we put on. Um
and
we say that the root, remember this is
the initial node,
is in a singleton information set.
The idea would be if we don't know where
the game starts, we don't know where we
are, then there must be some prior move
that we didn't observe, and we should
model that explicitly.
So, if you don't know where you start,
then often the way we capture that is we
say that nature is initially making a
move that determines where we start.
But, then nature has a has a node that
starts the game. So, the root or the
initial node must be in its own
information set.
And you see that that was satisfied here
and here.
Okay, a few final
points.
Check the time.
So, I've been a little sloppy uh in a
few things, and that's that I've been
talking a lot about players, but nature
is really different than the other
players. So, we need to specify some
different rules for nature.
So, let me say nature is different.
If you just look up at these trees, can
you see any differences when we
label a node to be nature rather than a
strategic player? What's different when
it's nature's turn? Yeah.
Nature like works on probability.
Exactly right. So, whereas a strategic
player chooses an action at an edge,
nature just chooses probabilities. So,
edges
have probabilities,
not actions.
And that's because nature is not
strategic. These just probabilities are
given to us.
With strategic players, we can't assume
that a player is always going to go to
the Celtics game with probability .2.
That's the whole point what we're trying
to figure out. Whereas nature, we do
think of it like a lottery, like a
roulette wheel. Um it these
probabilities are just fixed as part of
the game, and all that nature does is it
mechanically draws an edge according to
those probabilities.
Uh any other things you notice that are
different about nature?
Well, one thing nature doesn't have
payoffs.
Right? When we labeled payoffs at the
end of the game, we only specified
payoffs for the strategic players in the
game, players one through N. We didn't
label it for it nature. So, nature has
no payoffs.
And then the final thing is remember
when I talked about information sets, I
said for each player I. That what I
meant by that is each strategic player
I. Nature also doesn't have information
sets. Wherever nature is, they just
mechanically draw their probabilities.
There's no sense of what nature knows
about other moves. We don't need to
worry about that. So, we have no
information sets.
Or an equivalent way of saying it is
every info set is a singleton.
I guess this is convenient because I
said the root
must be a singleton information set.
Well, if the if the root is a move by
nature, technically I should say nature
has a singleton information set if I
want to be consistent with this
definition. But, this that's nothing
about interpretation. It's just we allow
nature to start the game.
And then I guess we often it can
sometimes get a bit cumbersome to keep
writing nature. So, often we just draw a
circle
to indicate nature nature's nodes.
So, for strategic players, we have a
filled-in circle, and for nature, we
have uh
a hollow or empty circle.
Okay.
Great. So, now that we've talked about
extensive form games, I'd like to move
on to strategies unless there's any
questions on extensive form games. We're
going to move on now.
Okay.
And maybe I'll say this is kind of
implicit, but nature also has no
strategies,
which we're about to define.
So, what is a strategy?
Well, I want you to put yourself in the
shoes of someone approaching this game.
Before the game has started, you're
contemplating how you're going to play
in this game.
And a strategy is the answer to that.
The strategy is
a complete
contingent plan.
So, it's a plan of action.
You analyze it at the beginning. You're
you're an outsider or you're one of the
players, but you're kind of uh
evaluating and assessing the game, and
you look at all the places where you
might be called upon to move,
and you plan ahead. You make a plan for
what actions you're going to take at
every node.
It's a complete plan. We have to specify
what you're going to do at every
possible contingency that arises.
So, I'm very often asked in in
section and uh office hours,
"Do I really have to specify this
contingency here?"
I've never been asked that question, and
the answer's been no. It's always been
yes. So, if you're unsure, "Do I really
need to specify this as part of a
strategy?"
Unless you're different than every other
student I've had before, the answer is
yes, you have to specify it. So, when in
doubt, specify.
Um
it turns out that's going to make your
life that kind of makes your life
easier, but I think we'll see that as we
go throughout the course. But, I'll just
say that uh maybe my answer is yes, you
have to include it.
Everywhere.
Even when you think you don't need to.
And contingent
is capturing the fact that you're going
to learn things over the course of the
game.
So, if for instance, these two nodes are
in different information sets, then
player two is going to learn what player
one does.
And therefore their plan is implicitly
going to be a contingent plan. It's not
going to say, "I'm going to go to the
Celtics game or I'm going to go to the
Red Sox game." It might say something
like, "I'm going to go to the Celtics
game if my friend goes to the Celtics
game,
and I'm going to go to the Red Sox game
if my friend goes to the Red Sox game."
And that's what's capturing the
contingency in a strategy.
So, that's the intuitive idea. What is
it formally?
Formally, it specifies an action at
every information set.
So, often a good way to write a strategy
is to put out some spaces for each of
the information sets a player has.
So, let's say a player has four
information sets.
Maybe this is information set one,
information set two,
information set three, and information
set four.
And the way you specify a strategy is to
specify an action here, maybe I'll call
it A1, an action here,
an action here, and action here.
So, how many information sets I have are
going to be determined by the structure
of the extensive form game.
But, once I have the extensive form game
written down,
I can list out
all the information sets for a given
player,
and then I can specify a strategy by
specifying what action the player will
take at each of these information sets.
So, the interpretation of this strategy
would be,
"If I find myself at information set
one,
I will take action A1.
If I find myself at at information set
I2, I will take action A2, and so on."
And of course,
the action that I take at information
set I1 must be a feasible action at that
information set.
Right? If it was infeasible, then it
wouldn't be um
it it wouldn't make sense.
But, here's a question.
I said this action must be feasible at
an information set.
But, an information set has many nodes.
So, does how does that make sense? Isn't
feasibility a property of a node, not an
information set?
Yeah?
One of the properties of an information
set is that every node has to have the
same feasible actions. Exactly. So,
because every node in information set
has the same feasible actions, I can
sort of think of the feasible actions at
an information set because it's the same
whichever node in that information set I
look at, and therefore it's meaningful
to say, "I'm going to take action A1,
which is feasible at this information
set." It just means it's feasible at
every single node in the information set
that I might be at.
And again, this is a contingency. We
often say, you know, "If it will do
this, but if it rains, we'll do this."
That's exactly what this is capturing.
"We'll do this, but if it rains, we'll
do this, and if it snows, we'll do this,
and if it's sunny, we'll do this.
Okay, so let's now
uh
take
this
right here.
So, we've defined an extensive form
game.
We've defined a strategy. I now want to
describe what a strategic form game is.
That's actually really easy, but then
what's harder is showing how we move
from an extensive form game to an
equivalent strategic form game. So,
let's first talk about a strategic form
game.
And the idea is, well, look, we wrote
down this really complicated extensive
form game,
but once we understand the concept of a
strategy, we can really simplify this
game a lot. What happens in this game?
Each player chooses a strategy.
They choose a complete contingent plan,
and then based on those complete
contingent plans, we can we can
calculate what's going to happen in the
game.
So, the strategic form representation is
a way of reducing the game simply to its
strategic components. So, what do we
specify? We specify the players as
before.
We specify the strategies.
Well, we'll call them we'll have sets.
So, we have S1
up to SN.
Big S1 is the set of strategies for
player one.
So, every element, every member of this
set is a particular strategy for player
one. We list all those strategies
together and put them together in a set
called big S1.
And we might have
use notation like little S1 is a
particular strategy that lives inside
this set of strategies.
And then it's often going to be helpful
to have notation for
profiles of strategies. Because if we
want to understand what's going to
happen in a game,
it's not enough just to know player one
strategy. We need to know what is player
one doing, what is their strategy, what
is player two's strategy, all the way up
to what is player N's strategy. So,
we're going to define a set capital S
is equal to
S1
times up to SN. So, what is this? This
is the set of all tuples or or pairs,
triples, however many we have, of
strategies. So, as an example, an
element of this might be something like
S equals
S1 up to SN.
So, this is the element symbol. So, what
I'm saying is S here
is a strategy profile.
So, this is going to this notation will
come up throughout the year, so I think
it's really important to make sure we
understand it. Little S is a profile of
strategies. It specifies a strategy for
player one,
a strategy for player two, all the way
up to a strategy for player N.
So, SN is the strategy
by player N in the particular strategy
profile S.
This strategy profile S lives in this
set big S.
This is the collection of all strategy
profiles in the game.
Yeah.
So, when we say that, we're saying it's
every combination of every strategy that
any player can
Exactly right. Yeah. So, that's what
this product notation is. We choose one
strategy for player one, we choose one
strategy for player two, all the way up
to N, and any collection of those
choices is going to uh give us the
strategy profile.
And then the last thing is just payoffs.
And
payoffs, we need a function UI
from S to R
for I equals 1 to N.
Now, some people attempted to put an I
here cuz they see an I here,
but that would be wrong. If we put an I
here, that would mean that player I's
payoff only depends on player I's
strategy.
If that were the case, we wouldn't need
to do game theory at all. That's just an
individual decision problem. What makes
it interesting is that the payoff that I
get as player I depends not only on what
I do, but also on what everyone else
does. And that's why there's no I here,
and the payoff of player I is a function
of the strategy profile. It says, for
instance, if there's two players, if
player one chooses strategy S1 and
player two chooses strategy S2, what is
going to be the payoff for player I from
that combination of strategies? Or in
other words, from that strategy profile.
Strategic form, it's really simple, but
you have to make sure you write down the
set of strategies correctly,
and you have to make sure you write down
the payoffs correctly. So, what we're
now going to describe is how we can move
when we're given an extensive form game,
how we can reduce it to a strategic form
game, reduce it to its strategic form
representation.
So, let me
go to a new board over here. Do we have
one?
So, what's our procedure for going from
So, it's not always the case, but often
when we start by considering some
strategic situation,
we write down all the details in the
extensive form to make sure we specify
everything exactly right. And then when
it's time to analyze the game, it's
often more convenient to reduce this
extensive form to this more compact and
convenient strategic form. But if you
try to jump right to the strategic form,
you might make a mistake. So, it's good
to be really careful about how you set
up the extensive form and then convert
things to the strategic form. So, how do
we do it? Well, there's two steps.
Or two
hard steps. I mean, one step is just
look at who the players are, but that's
pretty easy, right? Once you have an
extensive form game, we see who all the
players are, and the players are going
to be the same. So, that's easy.
The the hard thing, or the two hard
steps,
are that we have to
define the strategy sets.
So, we'll do an example in a second, but
a strategy set would be something like a
collection of all vectors that look like
this. That would be an example of what
the strategy set will be. But to define
it correctly, you have to make sure you
specify all the information sets
correctly and all the possible actions
that can be chosen at those information
sets.
And the second step
is to compute
the payoff functions
UI
S to R.
That is, once I've defined the strategy
sets, I still have to say,
if you give me a strategy profile
specifying a complete contingent plan
for each of the players,
what is the payoff that player I is
going to get from that profile?
So, why is this hard? It's hard because
from the extensive form, what we know is
the payoff each player gets from a
consequence, from a terminal node in the
game.
And now we have to compute what payoff
they get from a strategy profile, which
is not the same thing as a consequence.
So, how do we do that? Let me give you a
maybe somewhat cryptic formula, and then
we'll do an example to see how we do it.
But the key
is that a strategy profile S
if we focus on a particular strat-
particular strategy profile S, that is
going to induce in the extensive form
game a lottery
over terminal nodes.
It's going to induce a lottery over
consequences.
So, maybe I'll write
Z of S.
And I'll show how that happens, but a
strategy profile induces a lottery over
consequences, and once we can compute
that lottery over consequences, we can
compute each player's expected utility
from that lottery over consequences.
Because remember, we've already defined
utilities over consequences. And that
expected utility is going to be the new
definition of the new utility function
that we assign to the strategy profile.
So, we'll do an example, but the step is
a strategy profile determines a lottery
over consequences, which allows us to
compute expected utilities, and those
are going to be the payoffs in our
strategic form game. So, let's do uh
let's do an example.
Let me go
here.
And we'll we'll end with this example.
So, we're going to think of the Boston
game we did before,
but it's a little artificial just to
illustrate ideas that
nature is going to flip a coin to
determine the order in which we move in
this game.
So, first nature is going to flip a
coin,
say half half.
I need to give myself some more space.
And
if the coin is, say, heads, then player
one is going to
move first, and their move is not going
to be observed.
So, how do we represent this?
Player one moves first.
They choose uh Celtics or Red Sox.
Their move is not observed. So, that
means player two
This is player
two, and we put a dotted line here to
indicate player two does not observe the
move by player one. And then player two
chooses Celtics or Red Sox.
And you can see it's going to get pretty
messy to write all the payoffs. So, for
now I'm not going to write the payoffs,
but the payoffs will be the same as in
the other game.
And if we do it the other way, let's say
if nature flips tails, then player two
is going to move first, but then their
move is going to be observed by player
one.
So, now we have player two here.
They're going to choose between
Celtics and Red Sox.
Now, it's player one's turn to move.
We don't draw a dotted line here because
player one observes what player two
does.
And then we have CR CR.
So, let's make sure we understand the
game.
Nature's going to flip a coin. These are
the rules. If the coin is heads, player
one decides first, then player two
decides without having observed what
player one does.
If nature flips tails, then player two
goes first, and then player one goes
after observing what player two did.
Yes.
So, like here then, does player two know
if they're like going first?
Great. So, let's look at the information
sets. So, how many information sets does
player two have in this game?
I'll open it up to everyone.
Or two, right? We have
information set here and an information
set here, right? Remember, this is
actually an information set I just
haven't drawn it. So, once we write out
all the information sets explicitly, we
can always answer questions like this.
So, when I'm here, well, I know that I'm
either at one of these two nodes. I know
that I'm not here, which means I know
the choice that nature made. I know they
flipped heads, but I don't know whether
player one chose C or R.
But you could like theoretically you
know they're not at like the same line.
Oh, a different game would be I put all
three of these in the same information
set. That would be a different game that
I could write down, but that's not the
game I've written down here. Exactly.
Yeah.
Any other questions on this?
Okay, so now the hardest step is
figuring out strategies.
So, I think especially when you're just
getting used to this, whenever you're
asked to write down strategies, the
first question should be how many
information sets does each player have?
Because often when people get strategies
wrong, it's because they've gotten the
information sets wrong. So,
let's look at player one and player two.
So, first, how many information sets
does player one have?
Yeah?
Three, right? Well, they have three
nodes, one, two, and three. And remember
what I said is I'm not going to draw, or
I hope I said this, I'm not going to
draw the singleton ones cuz it's just a
little messy. So,
technically
it's like this, but I'm just not going
to draw those. So, if you don't see the
nodes connected, that means each node is
in its own information set. So, player
one has three information sets, and each
of these information sets is what we
call a singleton. It has a single node
in it. So, player one has three info
sets.
And what about player two? How many
information sets does player two have?
Two, right? Information set one
and information set two.
So, why is it good to ask how many
information sets are first? Because you
can think of a strategy as a vector, and
the number of places in the vector is
going to be the number of information
sets. So, each information set is going
to have a slot in this vector, and then
we're going to fill in those slots.
So, what is let's think of strategies
for player one. We're going to have
three slots.
And strategies for player two,
we're going to have two slots.
Why slots? Because a strategy specifies
something for each information set. So,
we're just going to specify a slot
wherever we need to put something.
Now,
the next thing is it's kind of helpful
often to number the information sets. On
the problem set, you could either
explicitly number them, or maybe you
could sort of indicate how you're going
to number it so that the TA understands,
but it's important that you're clear
about which of these slots each
information set corresponds to. So,
maybe I'll label player one's
information sets
I
2I
and 3I.
I didn't want to use one, two, and three
cuz that is confusing with players.
And then for player two, um I guess I'll
do
I
and 2I.
So,
Okay?
So, now let's fill this in.
We can just give an example. So, we have
three information sets. To specify a
strategy, we just have to put Celtics or
Red Sox here, Celtics or Red Sox here,
and Celtics or Red Sox here.
So, how many strategies are we going to
have in total for player one?
Eight strategies, right?
And what about for player two?
How many strategies?
Four, right? So, in general,
I mean, if
it's a bit more complicated if you have
more than two moves, but whenever you
have two moves at every information set,
the reason we get eight is this is two
to the three. The reason we get four is
this is two to the two.
Because we have two choices here. For
each of those two choices, we have two
choices here. And for each of those two
choices, we have two more. So, you can
uh it's sort of like a tree, it keeps
doubling each time, and eventually
you'll get eight. Um okay.
So, that's a lot to write down. If we
really want to specify this game, we
have to specify utilities for every
strategy profile. So, we're not going to
do it now, but let's just understand if
there's eight strategies for player one
and four strategies for player two,
then all together, we have 32 strategy
profiles. Because for each of the eight
strategies of player one, we can combine
it with the strategy for player two. And
then for each of those profiles, we have
to specify two numbers, the payoff for
player one and the payoff for player
two. So, all together, we need to
specify 64 numbers in this really,
really small game.
And I think this is sort of illustrating
why games like chess,
no one's able to even we can't even deal
with the number of strategies in chess,
right? It's many, many times larger than
the number of atoms in the universe,
right? Like the atoms in the universe to
the atoms in the universe. I mean,
crazy, crazy numbers.
Um
and the reason for that is, well, you
can see here, even in the simplest
possible game, uh it's combinatorial.
It's exponential.
Okay, so let's just do uh one example to
see how we can calculate these payoffs.
So, let's say uh
player
one is going to choose um
Let's say
it doesn't really matter. I'll just
choose it
arbitrarily. Let's do that. And let's
say
player two is choosing RC. Okay?
So, what I'd like to do is I'm going to
take this strategy by player one
and this strategy by
uh player two, and I want to compute
what the payoffs are going to be for
each player. So, I'm basically filling
in two of those 64 numbers that I have
to fill in if I wanted to fully specify
the game.
Okay?
So, what's often helpful
is
Let me start with player one.
And I'm going to going to go to each of
player one's information sets, and I'm
going to highlight the edge that the
player would choose at that information
set under this strategy.
So, information set one is here.
If player one finds himself at this
contingency,
this strategy specifies that that player
chooses C.
So, I'm going to highlight this here.
If player one finds himself at this
contingency, he's going to choose R.
And at this contingency, he's going to
choose R as well.
Now, let's go to player two.
At this contingency, this is information
set one, player two chooses R.
So, I'll fill this in with R here.
And now, this one is trickier. At this
information set, she chooses C.
But now, what do I fill in? Well, what I
have to do is I have to fill in C at
both nodes.
Why? Well, when player two gets here,
player two can't observe which node
she's at.
She just always does C because that's
what the strategy says. So, if it turned
out she were at this node, this is what
she would choose. If she were at this
node, this is what she would choose. She
doesn't know which one she's at, she
just plays C at that information set.
Okay?
So, now that we filled this in,
what we want to do is kind of trace
through the graph to try to compute what
the induced lottery over consequences is
going to be.
So, we start here.
If nature chooses heads,
which happens with probability 1/2, we
go here.
Then player one chooses C,
and then player two chooses C.
So, we're going to get this outcome
with probability 1/2.
If nature chooses tails,
then player two chooses R,
and then player one chooses R, so we're
going to get this outcome with
probability 1/2.
So, remember over here, I said a
strategy profile for the players
induces a lottery over consequences.
That's exactly what happened over here.
We computed a strategy profile. This is
the particular strategy profile. What is
the lottery it induces? The induced
lottery is we get to this history with
probability 1/2, which means we both go
to the Celtics game after nature flipped
the coin heads,
and we get to this consequence also with
probability 1/2. What is this
consequence? Well, it's this full
history. Nature chooses tails, then
player two chooses Red Sox, and then
player one chooses Red Sox.
And now, if we go back, we can compute
the expected payoffs from this strategy
profile by looking at 1/2 times the
utilities here
plus 1/2 times the utilities here, and
that's going to give each player
player's expected payoff from this
strategy profile. That gives us two
numbers, and we only have 62 to go.
Obviously, I'm not going to ask you to
do things like that on problem sets, but
that's in principle how it would work.
Uh any questions on this?
Yes.
Uh so, I would say this is a new
extensive form game.
So, I I define this new extensive form
game to try to illustrate some of the
concepts. So, this is not the same as
the extensive form game uh we did
before. Uh the reason it's important to
introduce moves of nature is that a lot
of games in reality involve randomness,
right? Um so, the way that we're going
to capture randomness more broadly is
going to be through nature. This is kind
of a silly example with nature flipping
a coin, but in reality it might be I set
my price uh
you know, the price at my gas station to
be this, and then there's a war in the
Middle East, and then the price of oil
changes, and that's that's a choice of
nature, right? So, it's going to be more
substantive things uh you know, I set my
price, and then there's an antitrust
case against my competitor, things like
that that I can't anticipate, and that I
form beliefs over are going to be
represented by moves of nature. But, I
want to be clear that this extensive
form game is not the same as this
extensive form game. These are two
different games that illustrate
different ideas.
Yep. Any other questions?
Yep. If you wanted to make it so that
the players didn't know
who was choosing first, Mhm.
>> would you just add all the put all the
nodes for each player into one
information set basically? Yeah, you
could do that. Uh and that would be
legal in this game because we just have
to check are two properties satisfied.
Is there a singleton that starts things?
Yes. And does the player uh
have the same set of feasible actions at
every node in the information set? And
that would still be true. Um I will warn
you that there are some weird things you
can do with information sets. Um what we
So, we've imposed a few conditions.
There's a few things we haven't imposed.
So, a natural assumption is that players
don't forget what they previously knew.
This is something called perfect recall.
You might find it strange if a player
takes a move and then later forgets what
move she previously took. Uh we haven't
ruled that out explicitly, but every
game we're going to study, maybe with
the exception of the last day of class,
will have this property of perfect
recall, and without it, you can have
some weird things. On the other hand, is
perfect recall really a good assumption?
I mean, you probably don't remember a
lot of things you did when you were a
child, so, you know, maybe in some cases
imperfect recall is is a good model, but
um that's something that that is up to
the modeler in this course.
Any other questions?
Okay, so let me stop there, and I'll see
everyone on Thursday.